welcome to the program Russian state
news is reporting that the head of the
Wagner mercenary group is under
investigation and that's despite a
recent deal granting him immunity after
his forces took over military sites in
southern Russia the Kremlin had said
that pragosian agreed to go to Exile in
Belarus and fighters who hadn't joined
the Mutiny would not be prosecuted for
treason let's get the latest on this
from Moscow from Yulia chapavalova who
joins us now developing story and an
interesting one in terms of the
narrative
if she is indeed so we see that Russian
news agencies are reporting that the
case against frigursion is still under
investigation uh the criminal case on uh
an armed rebellion was initiated on
Friday evening after pregosian accused
the Russian military of shelling the
positions of the Wagner group and
announced a March of Justice against the
leadership of the Russian Ministry of
Defense on Saturday evening Kremlin
spokesman admitry peskov told reporters
that the criminal case against pregosian
would be dropped and frigursion would go
to Belarus and his Wagner merceries will
participate who participated rather in
the Rebellion would not be prosecuted
and some of them some of the finances
would sign contracts with the ministry
of Defense at the moment preggers
whereabouts are unknown we know nothing
about it but what is going on now you're
right it is a developing story of course
we'll have to wait and see what's going
to happen but it's quite interesting
probably it is it can be called an act
of dis an act of Disobedience from the
from the side of the Russian
investigative committee and the FSB
because of course from the Kremlin
earlier on we had
a bit different information indeed I
mean one thing we can confirm it seems
that images of the defense minister
finally appearing
that's right the ministry of Defense
early released a video showing Minister
shoigu visiting the command post of the
western group of the Russian forces the
group is deployed into the lugansk front
and this is shogu's first public
appearance since uh Evgeni fergusions
armed rebellion and would began getting
reactions from uh from correspondence
and Military bloggers here saying that
uh shoigu was now revealed to the public
as if nothing had happened so his
appearance is ruling out theories about
his possible resignation uh whether
there will be
rearrangements within the ministry of
Defense it's hard to say now but the
demand for them in the troops and in
society is very significant for the
latest thanks very much Julia Pavlova
therefore it's in Moscow